I did it I've stopped doing
that it's trust me it's a good thing but
Trevor Wallace why not do it special
throwback b b Bap for Trevor Wallace who
is on the show today he has a special on
Amazon he's hilarious he's a dream love
having him on uh without further Ado
Trevor's on the way but here's a little
Ado I have a little further Ado actually
I have some shows coming up in Erie
Pennsylvania on June 28th I'm going to
be at the Warner Theater I'm going to be
in Las Vegas Nevada uh July 20 24 on
July
6 sorry guys I'm my dlex is definitely
getting worse going to be at the Mirage
July 6th next year all new material then
July 17th I'll be in Alberta Canada at
The Great Outdoors Comedy Festival I
also have a special out brand new
special on
of.tv Whitney you can also go see the
roasts that we did uh the roast of bur
CER the roast of me and then my special
which is called mouthy out now
of.tv Whitney it's totally free there's
no catch love you enjoy Trevor Wallace I
love that you're
so potted out that you're like save
it yeah like you're like that's the most
podcast host shit ever like it's weird
cuz you're always like I think they
should just start recording the second
you get there but then it feels like
you're automatically on no one wants to
hear about the traffic on the way like I
like I know every time let me are we
recording
Pap like every time I go see like Bobby
Lee or Santino we about to record Bobby
lives under a bridge that's he's a troll
I love him no I love Bobby just with him
literally uh I'll get there and I'm like
a I couldn't find Park they're like save
it I'm like save it yeah every podcast
has in the history save it save dude
that sneeze save it shit like the this
isn't the gold I'd like to open for you
know on with your audience but yeah it's
always I hit a moose on the way here
dude save it no like my car is broken
like I got to go can I pee real quick
let's talk about it on the podcast I saw
a man get murdered today dude save it
save it save it yeah or like I need to
just like I feel insecure about my dude
on camera like can we have one
interaction that's not monetized is that
okay no can we no can we have one moment
not for public consumption CPM is my
life I need to know how much money I'm
making per second by the way do you feel
like that now like when you run into
comedians like I feel like I don't want
to have too much fun because I'm like
well we should be Rec like oh right why
are we doing this for no one yeah well
it is funny like when I'm recording with
any comic it's like so Ry back and forth
back forth he's like wow this guyy such
a good conversation and then the
camera's com and go get lunch and I'm
like it's like awkward do you like stand
up do you do you like me as a person
like it feels like I don't know what it
is but it's like it has like first dat
energy you're like we were just riffing
for an hour The Improv then you go to
swingers and you're like so what made
you move to LA so like when no one's
paying us all of a sudden we can't get
it up I think like the uh the
environment of comic Club is so fun and
Lively and you just it's very riffy
there and then you're just alone you're
like uh have you ever hang out with
comic during the day that'll really your
life no you can't it's like seeing it
Snail out of it shell you're just like
who yeah you can't you're like somebody
should put you you made me think of a
joke from your special out now
pterodactyl on Prime video out get it
watch it it's hilarious I'm really proud
you know that I I feel the need to say
this I wanted to not like you when I
first found out about you and you just
wormed your way in you're you kill me I
it eats me up inside thank you so much
and and before the joke you were talking
about I went to you for a lot of advice
on the special a lot of stuff so you
were like a mentor in this you're you're
a free EP free pee you get no credit but
you get mental credit this is me giving
a special thing free pee yeah fuck did I
I don't know the special things it's
hard it's hard making a special because
the hardest part about making a special
is you're so good on stage um you've
been doing this for so long you're so
comfortable and then all of a sudden you
know I always call it like it's always
an away game when you're shooting a
special it's at a theater that you're
not you know used to it's you got
cameras all of a sudden and then all of
a sudden you see someone that's like
really great live being a little bit
awkward right and you know it's just
kind of like the idea is to capture the
same energy that you would have live in
a special and there's just like a couple
little tricks and when I love somebody I
always want to make sure they know them
because a lot of comics don't share
tricks like why why aren't we all just
you know passing them on I made a lot of
mistakes and I wanted to pass them on
well that's what's great about is I can
talk to the people I look up to and be
like these are all massive things that I
learned and then hopefully I can pass it
on to somebody sure but I cut you off
you said something that reminded you of
a joke oh yes um but yeah no I hope I
wasn't micromanaging because I would
like at 2 am wake up and be like make
sure the AC is on the night before so
important and like all these things I
took advice from just like so many
people I could just because this is my
first special it's it's eight to nine
years of standup in one it's like other
than that uh you know I'm really hoping
that it does well if it doesn't whatever
but I want Amazon you know if they come
back to me and be like hey we went on
another special in two years it's like
this is the one that's like going to
have the most time and comfort come put
into it but as you know the second
special after they're like hey they won
it nine months you're like I have 12 new
minutes time to start riffing about
brown paper B yeah ex I got to start
fucking yeah which is funny it's like
you know clean your room when a date's
coming over that's well you're you live
in a goddamn Palace stop pretending you
to just buy a house yeah I know but I
still I still make my own bed Whitney I
made it and I sleep in it but it feels
like that that's like the UST she being
like hey you want a special N9 months
let me get my together yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you're just like on Reddit just
looking for setups no but I um it's
interesting because I feel like my first
special nobody told me not to yell I was
yelling like the way that you would in a
I'm doing it now the way that you would
in a big theater to try to get to the
back row but you have a microphone
you're miked like you know people are
watching it on a smaller screen it's not
a live show and then in my HBO special
nobody told me the secret about you have
to turn the AC and the venue on the
night before so my first show I came out
instantly sweating it was so I only was
able to use one show that's what I was
going to say it probably fucks up
continuity cuz then the second show
you're cool as cucumber but you're
cutting back and forth It's like there's
just a sweat ring disappearing unless
you're Lou CK in which case you'll just
he will literally intercut between two
shows and he'll be drenched in the setup
and dry in the punchline and you're like
good for you man and do you think people
pick up on that or do you think only
people who shoot a lot of edit a lot of
pick up on that or do you think the
average person not average person but
like the average viewers might just like
I had no idea I think people get more
have gotten more and more Savvy because
we talk about this the time on podcast
so I think that like comedy fans kind of
Will and also the quality is I think
once you're Louis CK no one cares and
there's something kind of charming about
it but when you're us you're like what
kind of asshole just in Cuts between
shows are you trying to manipulate us
why aren't you using you know what I
mean and a lot of this isn't one show
yeah a lot of times when you have to cut
between shows there might have been a
technical issue there might have been
something but like Lou like earned the
benefit of the doubt where I feel like
you and I would still be under the
microscope yeah I I get that people are
so wholesome when they ask questions
like a lot of people would assume it's
just one show a lot of people also and
I'm sure you haven't got this question
in decades but like I still get okay
okay okay not not decades let's just
slow down sorry sorry
with the with the decades so back in the
Roman era the Roman Empire when you
started so my first talkie yeah
yeah you didn't do MSG you did the the
Roman Empire where they throw stones at
you no I back when I was the Court
Jester for King Arthur yeah everybody
had black and white Vision back then I'm
just trying to say like you're so
established in this world people I'm
sure people still say dumb things to you
but like I'll have a friend come to show
and they'll be like yo how much of that
is uh did you just come up with that off
the Dome
is that just all improv you first of all
you need to stop hanging out with people
that say Dome oh well that's I don't
know if you know my fan base instead
head okay yeah yeah but like yo is that
just like do you do you think of is that
just like right off off bat but what I
will say is you do you are so good off
the cuff and you are so comfortable so
people don't ask me that because I think
you know that I've prepared what I'm
doing for the most part this the special
that I just did for ofv I do have like
do a lot of in it and I started putting
crow in the specials just so people know
that I do have that skill set because I
think my standup feels very written in a
way that I'm proud of and a way that I'm
proud of yeah I mean like you're just
doing the art form you're also like let
me show you what Mama's Cooking Mama can
out but also I only saying Mama because
you're pregnant okay thank you I thought
you were calling me fat which is all
also fine no I would never imagine the
arrogance that will come with scheduling
doing a special I'll just come up with
it when I get there like what oh I oh of
course like your friends are even dumber
than I thought because do even Domer um
because you think that I paid all this
money to get a camera crew here Amazon
and I'm just I'll come I'll come up with
it on the day yeah yeah I'll figure out
the jokes when I I love those guys but
that's also a barometer for like when
we're in the edit Bay and we're like oh
no the mic's my right hand no now it's
my left hand it's like these guys don't
even know yeah what like they just think
that you just walk up there and be like
dating is crazy and like dude this guy
gets it like think that we're just like
so when I get in my head over too much
about continuity or something I go like
dude the the average bro one of my
homies watching this thinks I rifted
this one hour I think I'm good on
continuity but uh I use the editor
Michael Schultz who you recommended the
best oh man what what a guy best I went
up to his his place and we like had an
edit day and it was fun it was like
collaborative and it just like it I saw
the special come to life which and I
have such control issues when it comes
to like videos and putting out it's like
this was kind of hard for me mhm because
I had to give notes but then also like
you know you know other people giving
their notes Amazon's giv their notes and
like I'm going against his uh Michael's
notes and we're kind of like but then we
like kind of came to aend and we like
was very collaborative well it's
interesting because you also have an
understanding of how your audience
consumes videos and content so it's like
I was interesting watching the special
because there were more wide shots than
I thought there would be cuz I thought
that you would go like oh no I mean you
can always punch in for t talk and you
can punch in for you know reels and
stuff like that but I remember being
like Oh I'm surprised he allowed so many
wide shots in here because I would
imagine in your work there's not a lot
of wide shots because you're you know
you're like have to cut it this is what
when you and I did the the roasts like I
and Pat remembers the nightmare of me
constantly wanted to punch in because I
was like people are going to be watching
this on their phone on the subway right
here wide shots you're just going to
look like a little duck yeah the wi
shots were nice to have to like kind of
cut away from or be like all right
that's a clean palet of that joke yeah y
taking a breather an interlude on a on a
CD like it just kind of like it moved in
a very um you know it's like I and I
love this about your work is it's very
intense and very like frantic in the
best way and cut very tight we had a
whole camera that was aimed to do in
camera snap zooms and there's certain
jokes where I would look down the barrel
of the camera in the first show they
were starting to get it second show they
got some third shows like they knew like
when I'd be like and I would like and we
and i' look they would point in because
I do so much punch Dooms on my videos
yeah I wanted it to feel like this is a
a sketch or it's like oh this has the
Trevor feel on it yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't want to be a face that's just a
plug and play it's like I want this I
want people to know that this is like I
am so invested in this project and it's
not just like a it felt very adult it
felt very like like like Trevor's
arrived yeah I mean I I've been
struggling with this just like that I
don't know how to perceive this I feel
nervous I feel excited I feel everything
and I was talking to a therapist IST
ladies what's up I go to therapy and he
was like.com promo
code promo code BT I don't he needs it
just kidding I love you BT but wait what
what do you go to therapy for do you go
weekly bi-weekly you go twice a week
bi-weekly every other week that's by
monthly no bi-weekly would be every
other
week right I think that's right
uh oh I'm me toing both of you fortnite
Le fortnite bi-weekly means twice a week
There's no way yeah you so aun comes
biek bi-weekly means occurring every two
weeks yes so you go every two weeks yeah
that's what I said to therapy don't try
to spit it on me right now why would you
just say twice a month cuz bi-weekly is
shorter it's one word who says biweekly
everybody comment every who goes to
therapy twice a month you're literally
like me you're just a guy who got proved
wrong you're like f who Who Says by
weekly when you could say I go to
therapy twice a month you know only
bisexuals gay you know leap year type
shit so mad that I got this wrong what's
by what does B monthly mean you the
months this is this is how I got
pregnant by the way not knowing how this
works that's so by monthly means every
two months are you going to stream your
birth I think I should don't you only
fans TV I know I should do it on only
fans there is money to be made I'm too
afraid I'll Poop everyone says during
child birth you either poop or die one
of the
two wow so you go to therapy every two
weeks yes okay and I just kind of talked
to him because I think I I wouldn't
really vent him that's a male therapist
yeah we could skip a week every two
weeks is fine yeah well it's I used to
go weekly and then my schedule just got
really busy and I would sometimes go and
I didn't have enough to talk about
that's the worst when you feel like
you're bombing for your therapist I'm
like 40 minutes in he's checking the
clock he's like so when you want to do
next week I'm like so God I'm kind of
insecure that n orazi got
SNL or I'm like asking him I'm like yo
what have you been up to how are you man
I will say the funniest thing is like
since it's Zoom therapy one time I had
like 10 minutes to kill before therapy
you know men rub the one out you hate
that saying Jer off I don't know what
the no I I always listened to your
podcast night my new thing I hate the
most is bricked up bricked up is great
bricked up is great that's how you got
the baby with me I hate it but ried up
but if you ever jerk out before therapy
or M before therapy it is hilarious you
click enter and he's like how are you
I'm like I'm lighting a cigarette I'm
like I don't even smoke but I'm good man
how are the kids he's like I don't have
kids I'm like up I'll see you next week
I heard on your podcast that you
sometimes jerk off on all fours uh I
guess that would be threes wait three
point St or that what was that or in
doggy style like doggy sty do you put a
hand on the wall I've done that how does
that I always thought that guys jerked
off by like the way that you like stand
at a urinol like with your hand up like
maybe if you're like
57 no I like what I'll do and this is
insane but whatever I'll like like as if
I'm in doggy like on like on the bed
with my knees kind of folded and then I
just put a uh an old t-shirt or a towel
and then you just kind of into it and uh
but yeah yeah then bada bing bada boom
and then you throw it on the ground and
you roll over and pretend it never
happened and that's my night time Mero
that's my little night cat so I'm sorry
I interrupted you we're talking to your
therapist about something oh just like
how I should feel about this and about
your special yeah it's just like it's a
lot of eyes at once and I'm used to if
something blows up it comes it stems
from like everything goes out to my
audience first and then if it gets big
and they share it then it kind of goes
viral and reaches out to the masses but
it's always like it play to the home
court first sure and then it gets shared
out but being on Amazon and Prime it's
like they just post it and I mean they
have a whole bunch of stuff there's like
a bunch of like there's like a BTS show
on there there's like sitcoms there's
romcoms so you could have no idea who I
am like let's just put this on and now
it's in front of you instead of like if
I post a video and it goes viral it's
getting shared out there and it's slowly
making its way to the people it's on
Amazon it's like after you buy some it's
like users who bought you know this
toilet paper to jerk off with also
watched yeah W terod yeah like what
products are you do you have to buy to
be suggested your special but that's
what's so cool about being integrated
with them essentially whole story uh the
therapist is like it's just changed you
don't like changing this is essent the
way I equate is like I'm in eighth grade
or an
uncertainty yeah it's like I'm in eighth
grade I'm going to high school in that
gap of like what's high school going to
be like this is the next level what does
this feel like and then tomorrow when it
comes out it's out now but like I'm
going to be a weekend be oh yeah this is
this is great like this is but is there
also some kind of like like um surrender
of control of not being able to watch
numbers and not being able to watch
views and since there's no view counter
it is kind of nice because I think if
there was I'd keep refreshing and I'd
want to know and I think now I can just
ask the people over at Amazon maybe like
a week or a month and see how it's doing
but also like specials are very much
word of mouth very I think it takes a
while you know you're going to be
putting it on your socials like
overnight Banger sometimes it is but
those are like the big anticipated or
the surprise drops like oh Chappelle put
out this yep yep but yeah I think it's
just it's just new to me I don't know
what to expect I haven't done a lot of
traditional and instead of putting it on
YouTube this was my version of being
like internet guy does traditional you
know I want to have the duality of both
yeah uh so I can be bi-weekly on that um
but so it's just new to me and it's just
I don't know there's a lot of un
certainties you have um uh a joke in
your special about first date energy you
brought it up earlier the dumbest stuff
you'll ever you must just be dating up a
storm dating a lot and I'm just trying
and how you meeting them so I just got
on a hinge like maybe a couple months I
don't really check that much it's weird
it's not it feels Li to
me now we're real friends don't lie to
me I'm not really what so you go hand
you pop in and then just pop out yeah I
I like we look at it because to me it
doesn't feel real mhm like if you meet
somebody after a show you give a number
you have a consensus of like kind of who
this person is but when you just match
somebody you exchange a couple messages
you're like what Equity do they have to
need to respond to me it's a video game
well you're famous G tell that to Ryan
are you still not on ran no way it's
like it's like an it's me and my friend
young gra the only two guys I know that
aren't on what's his last name who you
you and your friend who young gravy you
know him
what massive rapper don't do this I'm
trying to make you look young when young
gravy just just say you I just learned
who June bug is or jelly roll no you
June bug that's that's the sh you have
equity in that's June shine I just
learned who June bug is what in
the I was going to say you've been
drinking but you have a child so I don't
know how do I hold on how do I go no you
know young gravy he's
he's just look in this camera and say I
know young gravy I know young gravy I a
big fan and
fun.com oo su su now is a leading online
retailer of sensual health and wellness
products offering the widest selection
of Premier brands for those of you that
are listening not watching I am using a
very sexy whip to the camera and I am
hitting myself in the eye um it has the
widest selection of Premier brands of
toys lingerie and accessories they have
everything from soft and sexy to hot and
spases so go indulge and find
Unforgettable presents and gifts for
people on your list at funlove.com
Discover look I just did you see me just
get um that's not called choked up but
that's a
different I didn't get choked up that's
later um no I wanted I uh there's a this
is a candle no this is wax wait this is
C oh it's a massage candle look at this
and the candle says this smells like
we're going to have sex it's all so
cheeky I love it discover the allore of
intrigue intimate products a collection
of Premier his hers and coup's toys
exclusively available at funlove.com the
collection features sensual toys in all
shapes colors and sizes each toy has a
sleek and playful design element and
multiple features and functions browse a
wide variety of vibrators beads bullets
rabbits G-spot toys dildos massagers
body wants and bondage kits and fine
whatever tickles your fancy Intrigue
intimate products are only available at
funlove.com for a limited time you're
going to receive 50 that's
5% off fun Love's exclusive Intrigue
collection when you enter the code good
for youf funlove.com again enter code
good for you receive 50% off Intrigue at
funlove.com you earned it so I'm
pregnant I'm going to doctors pretty
much constantly I mean it's kind of all
you do uh I had a thyroid thing uh my
hair just randomly started falling out I
didn't know if it was connected to the
thyroid thing but you need a doctor to
tell you because if you go on WebMD
you're just going to think you have
cancer I also needed insoles because my
feet started looking like legumes I had
weird broken blood vessels I have one on
my eyelid uh so I had to go find like a
laser for that it's just a nightmare but
thank God for Zach dooc a free app where
you can find amazing doctors and book
appointments online we're talking about
booking appointments with thousands of
toprated patient reviewed doctors and
Specialists you can filter specifically
for the ones that take your insurance
are located near you and treat almost
any condition you are searching for like
an eyelid burst blood vessel these
doctors all have verified reviews from
actual real patients not Bots the
average weight time to see a doctor
booked on Zach do is between just 24 and
48 hours that's it folks you can even
score same day appointments take that
nightmare Healthcare in America Zach do
is coming to save the day once you find
the doc you want you can book them
immediately with just a few app Taps no
more awkwardly waiting on hold with a
receptionist no more listening to weird
saxophone music for 20 minutes only for
the call to be disconnected and for you
to call back and the reception is being
disgusted by how Despicable you are for
wanting to get that skin cancer cut off
your face I'm sorry am I bothering you
ma'am with my skin cancer I use Zach do
when I'm in a jam or when I'm in a
pickle Zach do handles both jams and
pickles when I have an issue that I
can't wait four weeks to get in for I go
to Zach do I find the doctor close to me
takes my insurance bada bing bada boom
and look at that my eyes is not bleeding
anymore what a concept go to Zach do.com
Whitney and download the Zach do app for
free and then find and book a top rated
doctor today that's zoc zooc
do.com Whitney
st.com Whitney do you really want to be
on Rya and be amongst these
tools I think that honestly it hurts you
if you're on if a girl sees you on R I'm
just going to hit X on all of them right
because I don't want or yeah do whatever
you want I don't care yeah and then if
you press their photo you can see other
photos of
themar what you're looking at creative
direct this guy is entrepr everyone is a
creative director everyone on that app
is a creative director this guy H is
that Jeff Dy no no
working at Olive Garden wait why Terren
okay not a bad looking guy a healthcare
consultant what does that mean xanx is
he going to put s say does he have oxy
yeah but his his bio is 41 on a dating
app just like I planned I don't know
look at the next photo also guys that
put their photo in black and white
always think they're cooler than they
are oh wait he he go back press him yeah
you'll see the other photos is there a
dog that's not his is there a girl
cropped out what is that why are you a
healthcare consultant with a head shot
thami
okay yeah no why does he have a phot of
a motorcycle no what's worse the fish
pick or the motorcycle and how and by
the way I do appreciate a guy that that
can fish yeah that's what the thing most
them just take me to Long John Silvers
and that's a bummer but I also think if
you're a healthcare consultant and
you're writing a motorcycle like I don't
know also when people like write too
much in their bio I'm
like
let's see read it uh single dad CEO
pilot first of all put work first fuck
that kid CEO then single B
pilot but this is a CEO like he
literally might just own Microsoft and
we have no idea is that Adrian Gren with
Down Syndrome uh it is okay don't out
the
person okay that's a good point oh great
pat give Pat another chore yeah let's
read the bio oh that's a guy from uh
that's uh don't say his name that's a
boy band guy that's Joey
Fone is this allowed I'm going to get
don't ruin my life wait connect with Jo
oh put heart and see if he matches with
him I know I will hit the heart but dude
for for being as successful as he is
let's get some more updated photos is
that you don't have one Getty
image who hard him and see if he harded
me also let me see what does the bio say
uh is it 98 have it let's make it what
makes me interesting no clue you be the
judge dude that's
fucking
huh it's no young gravy yeah yeah hard
but if I was on here that's this is my
competition
harded he didn't we didn't match not yet
okay there's a dog AC trying to make
love with me I'm sorry um wow that was
that was exciting this is why does it
feel exciting is that there's lots of
celebrities on here I remember is that
how girls feel when they see me on hinge
oh my God yeah kind of what's your hinge
um what's the line what line what's my
screen name like what's your no what's
your like line I have a gun is it no
that's actually a really good
one that's great actually I would swipe
right on that no I for I don't I don't
know there's like like a bunch of
different prompts it's not just like one
well what is it
uh well I I answered one of the prompts
and it was like what most irrational
fear I said the movie bugs
life uh what do women say about you I
and I just like overly
exaggerating here I was like I'm just
too much of a lover and then like a
bunch of like emojis like like this one
like like jokingly like cringe on
purpose yeah yeah yeah and then uh
what's it was like what's your hot take
I was like sprinkles I was like croutons
are just sprinkles for a
salad okay yes it's just stupid shit
silly goose so what is a um something
that bothers you that girls put in their
dating profile I'll tell you love this
it's a lot of the same and I don't think
I have a I don't think girls know that
they're doing they the same I don't
think guys do either so like on this on
the Ria dating app you can add a song
and when I tell you 20% of the guys put
mbot by Hansen because they think it's
like funny it's like a stupid song like
or a little put a joke song and it's
like I know you think this is funny but
most guys do it what's the thing girls
are doing like that it's a lot of the
it's literally not an
influencer get out I need an influencer
I'm kidding R flag but it'll be it's
like the same thing as like just need
somebody to get spicy margaritas with
looking for the best espresso Martini in
town or it'll be like what what's your
age you need to go younger it sounds
like you're dating women in their 40s
Ros all day no all no all these hand is
filled with alcoholics every girl on
there is like just the place to drink
apparo Spritz just the place to get me
out of my HR job he he alcohol it's like
what about a book whoa they're like you
don't need to roofy me I'll pass myself
out that's what I write no I don't that
but it's a lot of like um it's like uh
one of the prompts is like I will fall
in love for you and then they right if
you trip me and I'm like what are we
doing on a tight five here oh gosh it's
like that it's a lot of it's a like it's
either that or it's like the most
rational fear like men which like yeah I
get there's a lot of guys out there but
as a guy how what am I supposed to like
heart that be like hey these guys suck
right oh that's a bummer not I don't
like being on there so it's like I have
just I don't check it actively I like
check it like I check the mail also do
you still get mail from the resident
used to live here do you ever return it
yeah no I like get their mail and this
bitch is about to go to jail I don't
know what to do it says like eviction
it's like please open there's bigger and
bigger stamps and I'm like what am I
going to find her so the mail from your
PR the previous owner of your house
you're getting a lot of wild shit yeah
and and they keep having like stance I
her stuff's going to collections because
you won't send her her mail I mean why
why am I a part of this what she's
clearly running from something it says
like foreclosure it says uh I got one
recently God it was like a word I hadn't
seen in a while it was like a good
thesaurus word um I don't know I um want
to know about these dates you're going
on what are women doing wrong on dates
with you I don't think it's what are
women doing wrong I think I just
like I think my
because I have a theory I think you need
to date a little older yeah for a bit
okay when I hear younger guys complain
I'm like they're like and then she makes
me take photos of her and then I had to
pay and I spent all this money and she
lives with nine roommates and she's and
I'm just over here yeah like in my fully
paid for H I'm like I may have a couple
lines on my face but like yeah yeah I I
I I just you know what I want I want a
girl who loves her job I don't cuz I
love what I do so great one that's a
great one so I like kind of look for
that if they're talking about work and
I'm like yeah oh that's that's that's Co
someone doesn't like their job they're
always going to be miserable and you
have to hear about it it's just I don't
care what your job is as long as you
love it well you also feel bad for
liking your job if I come back she how
are the shows so great so fun just did
this city it was awesome I got a
premiere on Tuesday I got this and that
and then you're like oh oh how how was
work oh was terrible you're
like I'm just over here loving my job
might be a little older I love my job
I've got athletic Greens in a glass
canister I've got hand soap in every
bathroom my paid off I'm going to
therapy weekly not even
bi-weekly I have a bowl of limes
downstairs real real limes damn and I
know what to do with them I don't I just
get the fake foam ones and bu cards in
every room I don't even know why do you
really this is what happened yeah I got
cards everywhere I got the real Anthony
fouchy I got a I got every fouchy
writing books now yeah that guy in a la
he started 2019 even the dogs are fired
up Jordan Peterson say it boy have you
ever dated someone
older
uh uh I've been on dates with women who
are older but not like dated how was it
different it does seem a little more
like is this a thing or not Mom got a
shot clock it does seem a little more
like we there's no room for games but I
like that interesting it's like I I need
a middle ground cuz like a 25-year-old
would be like he he play games I'll text
you in four days I'm like what do you
mean uhhuh you're gonna snap streak yeah
four days see you know everything I'm
very young young gravy just little teen
mom here yes what a show that was 16 and
Pregnant what was it Teen Mom all those
wild but 20 so like 25-year-olds play
too games because it's like I want to
I'm hot I need to have some mystery I
get that right but you also you bite
when you give blowjobs I can I already
can tell yeah of course you use your
teeth you still haven't figured that out
what's all this are like on Snapchat
sucking you off you're like are we
making money on this use The Flash come
on um or I mean if they're like you know
a little older than me then it it feels
very much like there was a big
relationship before you oh and now you
don't know how soon after also like
hinge feels like an emergency room where
everybody's just like injured and you're
like who's who needs to be seen first
yeah yeah and there's like a 39-year-old
who's like I've been through all of it
and I don't even have health insurance
and then there's like a 25-year-old
who's like I just got a little cut but
I'm okay but that cut is deep cut is
deep and then I'm in there just
delusional and she got the cut from a
Tik Tok challenge that went horribly
wrong yes or next she's in there because
she ate a tide pod but it just feels
like you're in a room where everybody's
coming from a story you know and you
don't know what that story is and a lot
of times it's just normal they weren't
dating or they dated a few relationships
but like you know what's interesting
about hinge is it tells you it'll be
like how new they are it'll be like new
here it's like oh so you're just fresh
out of a relationship yes nobody's just
like sitting around for eight months
like oh I could use a dating app what is
this I definitely go back on the dating
app after something's over yeah but like
I'm definitely like someone distract me
so that's the worst energy to go into it
with exactly and also so they haven't
healed from that previous relationship
so they're still I haven't healed from
six relationships ago yeah yeah cuz
you're just like I feel like do you ever
take time to just be single and like not
that's what I'm doing like right now but
you're actively not dating I'm not
actively dating but if it comes up
organically you know I think also the
last part of the last like three months
was a lot of touring it was in Australia
it was in New York I was doing all this
promo all of this for this leadup of
tomorrow and then after that December
I'm not doing I'm going to be here I'm
so excited just to settle in and just
enjoy whatever I've worked to accomplish
and then when I have like a clear head
and not like this like because in my
head right now it's just like a bunch of
people yelling like you know just like
where's this promo we needed this
special but like December like the whole
industry off yeah agents and managers
they don't do in December they go out of
office yeah but you don't really what
are Agent Man and agents managers doing
for you I guess sponsor stuff they do a
lot well touring like I love oh of
course touring and sponsorship I love my
team but like don't say team okay what
what is that inclusive no just don't say
team don't say my team don't say I love
my team my
squad my Army your set of Domes my set
of Domes my paid domes no I the people
that I work with not my team my team I
love them they're so good but I told him
I was like I don't want to do anything
in December cuz I just want to like let
all the noise kind of like chill out
then I can be like okay what do I
actually want to do yep and it's also um
do you remember the show cheer on
Netflix about the cheerleaders that came
out during the pandemic you either
watched it or you didn't and it was it's
about the best cheerleading squad in the
country and
amazing Pat stop laughing at him boost
his audio anything boost his audio I'm
on your mom's houseat is only laughing
at you this episode and I do not
appreciate am I getting more laughs Rob
rle I
don't yes can it can somebody get more
laugh they're louder they're definitely
louder and it's kind of Rob's great
Annoying um Pat never annoys me today's
the first day that I cannot stand you
Pat welcome to my
team I know team I feel like today's the
day you're gonna poach bat um I forgot
what I was to say oh so this girl Morgan
um gets really famous off cheer she gets
3 million followers on inst real show or
real show okay called cheer it's about
the it's about a a cheerleading squad I
don't know if you ever saw saw last
chance you it was a documentary same
people made you had a friend that was on
it maybe were you probably yeah yeah so
like the coach is a good friend of mine
now from Cheer became a really big show
um if you watch it you'll love it in
December when you're catching up on life
anyway so she's they did this huge tour
they get really famous she's got like
paid Partnerships with scrunchie and her
own line of spandex whatever she
tampacks also if I'm blowing up in
scrunchies knocking at the door I'm like
bitch bring me Bentley scrunchie imagine
having a meeting with the CEO of
scrunchie we like to do four billion in
Revenue with you like that's great so
Morgan gets really famous and I see her
backstage in Austin after she does this
huge show it's 20,000 people they're
doing like whatever and I asked her I
was like so what are you gonna do you
know for the summer you know and she
goes you know I'm just going to take off
some time to process yeah and I was like
I don't like I don't follow and she's
like no like this has just been crazy
I'm just going to take some time off to
just like Pro I was like I have never
processed anything that has ever
happened to me I haven't processed
getting not even your
food I not getting like successful or
that you sometimes we just have to take
time to just stop and think because
we're just and stop doing a bad
impression of ourselves especially after
specials I think you really have to like
stop down and make sure you're not just
doing a bad impression of who you used
to be yeah well you also have to like
write new material and you and you sure
you can look back at the old archives
the got cut that didn't make it or
you're like okay where am I at in life
right now looking around what okay so I
want to start writing from here forward
you know you just got to kind of process
what's your like writing process do you
sit down and write uh so it's it's a
mixture of things like my notes app is
just flooded with full sentences half
you a word a paragraph uh it but voice
memo is really where I I talk a lot of
things out and then I in in talking it
out I go okay that's the opening that's
kind of the middle this is what I would
end on and then I kind of just try it on
stage and then condense after that are
you secretly insecure cuz I
yeah are you in this is terrifying for
me the fear of people hating me the fear
of irrelevancy the fear of the the scary
part about the internet is once people
decide it's hard to change their
judgment about you the internet will
just turn on somebody and once they've
turned I like I don't know an example
but I think it's just sometimes it's out
of your
control and I I just always want
to be liked on the internet because
maybe I came from a place where I wasn't
super liked like I was with the cool
kids but I was wasn't the coolest kid I
was in the back with the cool like in
high school yeah you weren't a cool kid
in high school I hung out with the cool
kids but I wasn't like the cool kid like
I they kept you around just so they look
cool yeah yeah I always had sunscreen on
me so like get Tre here but like I the
way I equated it was like I was on the
Lakers but I was on the bench you know
cool team but like not main player right
but don't you think the cool kids are
like didn't make it in life yeah and now
the bench players are coming up yeah cuz
all these guys are heroin Revenge of the
Nerds it's not cool don't be cool in
high school dude be a nerd maybe don't
even be cool in college I mean the jocks
like are just lose I mean every person I
know that was like a big jock that
everyone thought was so cool has like a
fentanyl addiction and like how do you
get addicted to fentanyl don't you just
pretty soon after I mean like I don't
know um but I I I think the insecurities
the stuff that I can't control so
something like this the special it's
just a lot of eyes at once and it's just
like
let's say you're just taking eight years
of work of standup and then just
condensing everybody's judgment on one
thing since I don't really post a lot of
stand-up clips and when I do it's crowd
work this is everyone's first judgment
on my like stand up standup and the
people that have seen me go up to the
clubs you're know you're one of them
you're like oh yeah he knows what he's
doing he's doing his thing like and
there is something that is I don't know
why this is but why is there still a
prejudice against people that got famous
online and we got like it can't be funny
as a standup like it can't what is that
why do that I CU why do I do that I
would yeah I would imagine that you are
thinking that they got a shortcut yep
it's like oh he didn't go to do the open
mics I did I was doing open mics in
college I moved here my first three
years I was just only doing open mics
there's like like I ran into some guys
at the store last night and we were just
talking about like the open mic could go
to every Monday it was called Big wangs
it was like a it was a a Wings Spot yeah
and it was like and we were just like
joking about the guys who came up out of
there and it's just like and not to say
that I'm like back in my day but it's
like you know you run into to these guys
and like all these people I know in the
LA I guess from my class in LA are like
yeah man you've put in a pretty good
amount of work yeah yeah but it's the
some random guy in De Mo watching the
special be like let's see what this
guy's all about but you watched it I I
watched it last night I was so impressed
um I honestly one of the hardest things
to do with the special is a
title oh yeah what were the runners up
this birds and the bees okay which uh I
thought was cool I didn't know if it was
to one note if somebody's like
like is this all just G be about it is
but uh what I like about pterodactyl
kind of reminds me of uh sigur's last
when Sledgehammer it's like it's one
word it's strong reminds me of jezel
Nick's like Caligula too like one word
and like or Chris Rock's tambourine like
I got to know what that joke is like I
got to know why he called it and I don't
even think pterodactyl is the strongest
joke in there by far but I just think
there's a few callbacks to it and I
think it's memorable mm 100% you know
and it's weird and it's like what and
it's just bold it's bold and like B you
just remember it you know if I named it
something like another one I had was
just a thought like just the thought
because I remember I was doing I was
doing a show I don't know what it means
yeah exactly it's well it's also like
not my it's too like whoa mysterious oh
just a thought what you know like the
other one was it's a little just like
huh it's not nor here nor there it
doesn't make me it would be called the
new Trevor Wallace joint or the new
Trevor Wallace special instead of ptera
or just Dome you know yeah also just a
thought it minimizes is it it's like
just a thing means it's not it's not
grandiose and Regal the other one is
going to be Spirit fingers from the
carrot cake joke or just carrot cake
Spirit fingers I liked I just thought of
the marketing behind it and I was just
like I was thinking about like just some
jack dude who only watches fucking
Andrew Tate is he G be like spe fingers
you think watch speit fingers what is
this cheer you know like I wanted I
wanted right down the middle where it's
like it's it's like a pterodactyl
doesn't inflict anybody's life it's not
like they're like I used to dat to
pterodactyl like it's just right down
the middle just like oh what naming
specials is actually really hard yeah
how did you come up with mouthy mouthy
was I all my specials I feel like people
looked at your Instagram comments you're
like this bitch mouthy and you're like
bingo I kind of like started realizing
that I think it really helps me to just
call myself out on the things people
accuse me of like if you just get
yourself it's hard to get got and I
think for the longest time I just tried
to course correct either my energy or my
personality or the way that I Ed myself
or the way that I write or the way that
I promote based on negative comments I
get and just hope that like they noticed
or just I'm in terms of negative
comments like I don't know for me
sometimes I think it's constructive
criticism and it's helpful saying like
she's a dumb like I don't really know
what to do with that yeah but like if
some go back to the drawing board with
that yeah I'm kind of like I don't
really know what to do if that's but if
someone's like oh my God why is she so
loud the jokes are good but she's like
yelling and I'm like you know that's a
good point I need to make sure that I
calibrate that later I need to stop like
you know acting like I have 5,000 people
are trying to reach the person in the
back row instead of just like talking to
the camera in a special like it took me
long I like the one word special it's
just it's quick because I always think
about specials are a lot of Word of
Mouth you know so it's like what are
what are two guys at work be like dude
have you seen that new what are they say
that new Trevor Wall special or dude
have you SE it's like pterodax or
something it's like some dinosaur but
some dinosaur is better than like it's
like a it's like just a thought what do
you mean oh like the special just no
it's called just I don't want any
confusion that's a really interesting
way to put it like when people name they
always ask me what they should name
their dogs and I always just say don't
name them anything that rhymes with a
command someone's like I'm maybe not my
dog B I'm like that's the worst thing
you could do oh really right B Because
Bo rhymes with no oh that's a terrible
name for a dog like Rambo it's like well
then when you say no they're going to go
like what you know what I mean a lot of
people come to you for dog names I I but
like it fits like I'm not even trying to
talk like that fits your energy in the
best way possible I also looked and I
was like oh that is how you spelled
terod like it just kept my attention
crazy word you like made a little puzzle
for people and I think that's s such a
big part of our job now is to just get
people's attention by any means
necessary yeah so what were the run-ups
for mouthy mouthy you know what for some
reason this one kind of stuck right away
yeah like I I I try not to be too
defensive but I kind of do tend to play
defense in my special title so the one
before uh I just the Netflix one before
this was just called jokes because I
felt like so many comedians were like
talk like doing these like
self-righteous monologues on stage and
we're settling for clapter instead of
actual jokes and it was like we're gonna
make a statement about gender and this
and I was like this is all just jokes
this is silly ridiculous jokes it's also
nice cuz you can't get mad at something
called jokes it's the same thing with my
podcast it's called stiff socks if you
like listen anything you're like wow I
can't believe these guys just said this
about it's called stiff sock socks what
is going on with you imagine putting
that in a public an article uh quoted
from the sticky suck podcast it's like
if you just go out like what you said
it's like if you call yourself mouthy
it's like and somebody comments it like
yeah she's really yeah she's got these
crazy opinions and and then if someone
is like oh she said this thing about
this in her special yeah because they're
jokes I don't know what to tell it's
also the same reason like doing it on
only fans TV it's like if I mean the
roasts like someone going like they made
a joke they said tranny on only fans TV
it's like dude that's the least Wild
Thing tun in for the second season
exactly you're kind of like well you
were the one that was down in the gutter
with us like you knew what you were
signing up for yeah so it's on ofv and
then are are you g to clip it up and put
it out a bunch of places or I think so
yeah I mean I'm the first person that's
ever you know done a special obviously
on ofv so hopefully it does well it's
kind of like on their homepage but you
kind of you know it's just of fv.
Whitney and it's free too which I think
helps because right now you're kind of
like just putting a link out you know
yes it doesn't really matter what the
freaking link is like I remember when I
did two BR girls like people would come
up to me and they would be like your
show changed my life I've seen every
episode I quit my job that I hate and I
started a new job because of it and I de
I live for two broke CL what episode was
that I didn't watch that shit it's like
IA the question I would always ask is oh
really it's your favorite show what
network is it on they'd be like I'm like
so you've seen every episode it's your
favorite show yeah and you can't even
tell me what network it's on but that's
that's always that's still a problem to
this day people will come up to me I
love your podcast and I go oh before I
even like finish I'm like say thank you
they're like yeah those clips are great
never seen an episode but I Love the
clips
there will be people who swe yeah
because they just follow the clips clips
are just like putting out it's like I
don't know it's like it it feels like
you're just putting kind of there and if
you get the bite they either like take
the bite and leave or that they get and
be like who what's what else what's the
common denominator in when your podcast
Clips asking for a friend um no they do
well like it's so interesting because I
I feel like I know how to write
television I know how to write movies I
know how to make specials but when
you're kind of like Christ stuan I love
you do I think your tubberware clip
should have been as big as him just not
being able to pronounce the word
Tupperware like are you like CU you're
so Savvy with social media are you like
I know why that did well I get why that
did well or sometimes you're just like
I'm kind of throwing fan and course
correcting and just yes and no I feel
like a guy like you can't like my I have
a a pulse on like what could do well or
if you give me a clip I can like tell
you how to edit it to try and get the
best clicks and Views I feel like I
don't know 100% but like it's like the
guys who know the stock market like oh
you should invest in this you know like
that's like my kind of bread and butter
but is it more gut instinct or is it
more like look 60c ones do well 40c ones
don't at 3 o'clock on Wednesdays it's
more so like when a clip goes big I can
go oh it got this is why it went big
it's got good retention rate it's got a
lot of sharability
um you know I've noticed that whenever
anything of mind gets big it's because
it's either topical trending or it's
very sharable when I make fun of a
certain type of guy like when I made fun
of like the Subaru people like the like
uh those creatures
uh it's just people watch it you watch
it and then you tag so and so who has
one and then it's very there's an action
to it and also like it's what great
comedy does great standup you're you
know which is like it's true like it
strikes a nerve it also has to be
correct but what's great is somebody
will watch it and then it has an action
item and they're sending it to their
friend and podcast Clips is kind of hard
cuz it's like usually people looking
dumb on podcast does better because it's
like look at these guys but like you and
I just having a
conversation somebody at home probably
wouldn't tag somebody in it to be like
this is so relatable because it's like
oh this is a great conversation but me
getting by monthly wrong or something
like that it's like oh I know people
that do that I had one that went kind of
I don't know about viral but it got a
views on our podcast because I thought
10 year you know ten year yeah I thought
that was 10 years
[Laughter]
is it not but like I had no idea no that
literally means forever yes but but I
thought you got 10 year by working at
like a school for 10 years it you know
what it's it's an honest mistake it's
not a bad mistake to make but what it is
it felt real uhhuh uh it it's like it
showed a little vulnerable sweet moment
cuz you're always so on top of it you're
so funny like exctly I think people like
that type of stuff yeah people like to
see a vulnerable moment basement yard
you know them Joe sanado and and Frank
so those guys have such good banter and
they're constantly like finding out
something about each other like hold on
you eat hot dog sideways like yeah
what's wrong with that and then it's
like it's like when you found out bird
drank Kool-Aid yes yes it's these innoc
so podcast Clips do well when it's like
these innocent Miranda I guess I do cuss
a little like like it was it was her it
was genuine and it's those know that I'm
still in a weird lawsuit
with her Aon about this
yeah me and Miranda are now suing each
other what acon so okay so you about to
be locked up so Miranda costro comes on
the podcast the I said what's your
favorite curse word yeah probably it I
think it might be the number one sound
on Tik I have one Tik Tok video that has
like
178 million views or something and the
rest are like 7 million 6 Mill you
should have named the special probably I
should have
so so this thing goes viral obviously um
and Aon does a song called probably fuck
and he takes the audio and it's like
what we gonna do tonight girl and he
goes probably fuck Miranda's voice is in
the whole thing wait who's suing he's
suing you no he it comes out and then
everyone's like you got you can't let
this it's also Miranda who's the
sweetest person and I'm like this girl
has worked so hard to she's the only
actress or performer you could that
hasn't
you know show she sounds stressed out
she sounds like she needs like a man in
her life right a man who's like Charming
man who loves dinosaurs all of a sudden
looks like he's staring into the sun I
don't know that my romantic face why I
don't know all right y'all know about
quip toothbrushes because you know that
I'm obsessed with them they're Sleek
they're Chic and they're actually
hygienic but they're water flosser do
you know about this water flosser I okay
so I hated flossing because you have to
use that tiny little rope and cut into
your fingers and just everything and
every one is bleeding it's no good the
water flosser hits all the right spots
with gentle or deep clean pressure at
the touch of a button look at this extra
wide lid that fits right under the
faucet fills up in seconds the cordless
rechargeable battery lasts up to eight
weeks with daily use no bulky charging
dock or Tangled cords that a burglar
could use against you when they intrude
into your home Blast Away up to 99.9% of
plaque from treated areas with Precision
thanks to the
360° rotating magnetic floss tip that
snaps right into place look at that boom
easy to control water flow that leaves
you feeling squeaky clean and the
toothbrush let's talk about that for a
second the quip electric toothbrush is
loved by over 9 million miles with
stylish Affordable Electric brushes they
start at $25 so you're not going to be
paying through the teeth for better oral
health that would just be too ironic
wouldn't it if you go to getquip.com
Whitney right now you are going to get
20% off any electric toothbrush mint and
gum dispenser or water flosser the
holidays are here you guys the new year
is here you can't be running around with
hosis okay you can't there's no excuse
anymore we're not wearing masks anymore
get it together get your mouth in order
20% off any electric toothbrush mint and
gum dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com Whitney spell
gq.com
Whitney
quip the good habits company it's the
holiday season I want to talk to you
about my favorite company on the planet
you know this about me it's called Etsy
if you're like me you are on a mission
to find handcrafted affordable gifts
made by independent sellers that's my
Kink whether you're searching for custom
home pieces like cutting boards Linens
and throw pillows for your favorite
holiday hosts or personalized items like
purses necklaces and seasonal jackets
for your most stylish friends and family
Etsy has it I buy literally everything
on Etsy you know this about me I just
bought a bunch of cottage core Prairie
type dresses literally I just type in
cottage core button Prairie dress collar
because I have decided that after I give
birth I would like to start dressing
like Dr Quinn Medicine Woman I don't
know how else I'm going to get a husband
um the edsy also kind of a dating app uh
they button at the top uh in case I lose
my mind and do decide to breastfeed like
a Amish person so I did all that I got
my my next year's um identity in order
it's great if you're engaging in Cosplay
trying to change your clothes in order
to change your personality I'm doing all
my holiday shopping on Etsy so what I
usually do is I'll just look up vintage
animal figurines it's a goal mine you
guys I find like the weirdest vintage
animals I can find gave them to my
friends for their desk or their home or
whatever cuz everyone loves a vintage
animal figurine and if you don't you can
kindly go to hell okay I also get
vintage holiday ornaments on there I
just type in Farmhouse Christmas you
will be dazzled by the visual Feast of
rustic stuff that heals your heart and
fixes your childhood that's what Etsy
does to me if you're new to Etsy use the
code holiday 10 for 10% off your first
purchase that's code holiday 1010
maximum discount value of $50 expires
December 31st 23 see terms at etsy.com
terms for handcrafted and affordable
gifts for everyone on your list Etsy has
it shop
etsy.com so who's suing who in this
Miranda I'm dying for you and Miranda to
get married the one what happened we'll
get married in your backyard is where
the her St almost killed her let's no no
no your backyard oh in my backyard it's
fine yeah the groomsman will be a coyote
okay so so the one time I was like oh my
God I'm going to like them up and
introduce them to each other you happen
to have a giant yeah the ber Cher I had
like a stomach on me with like chest
hair and I messaged her the next day I
was like hey sorry I met you with a fake
stomach on
nothing text you bad but we follow each
other so there is something there yes no
she watches every podcast so it
was what someone tried to kill her with
a gun maybe that's why I switched to the
Heart s the heart swi the heart so yeah
so literally who's suing who you're
suing Aon so Aon so they're like oh we
need to send him like a season to cuz
also let have it it's a he's got a big
dick if anyone else wants it they can
have it especially just cuz he got money
no do you remember when he like humped a
14-year-old girl on stage and then he
said put a song out about it and then he
well and then have you heard the apology
song that he did okay I talked to my
friends about this recently like it
blows my mind they're like hey man you
you should probably apologize and he's
like I will I'll also make millions of
dollars doing it but by the way he and
he drags Gwen Stefani in it to apologize
the things I've done and things that
haven't occurred yet all the things he's
protecting himself in the future when
he's smart this is a the lawyer wrote
this song but he also I'm sorry for the
times I left you home I was on the road
and you were alone I'm sorry the fact
that I did not know now it gets past
aggressive sorry for all the things I
did not know cuz I can't read your mind
gas he's being such an asshole this is
okay you can tell who what the lawyer
wrote versus what he wrote he got notes
and then he's like but the funniest part
is he brings Gwen safani in he's like
he's like I was on tour with Gwen safani
she's like leave me out of it can I
please not deal with this but yeah he
made a song about it and it's got like
millions of like views and
streams I understand that there's some
problems yeah you humped a 14-year-old
on stage how did the publisher be like
oh yeah put that out and he's like oh no
this is about a friend I'm sorry all the
things that he put you through who's
that third person and I'm sorry for the
times you didn't know what to do this is
the worst nursery rhyme I've ever read
oh and even though pops treated us like
Kinks he got a second wife and you
didn't agree it doesn't even rhyme like
that's how badly they're um get wait can
you read the part about Gwen safani I
just love how she just catches a stray
in this that is so I'm sorry for club
Zen getting shut
down okay that was personal that's one
of the lines here it got shut down
because of this I'm sorry that it took
to too long to see and they were dead
wrong trying to put it on me I'm sorry
that it took so long to speak but I was
on tour with Gwen
Stefani like but that's actually a good
lyric because her she has a song called
Don't
Speak oh so that's actually what that
was right I mean it's like funny to flex
in an apology I wanted to do a video a
long ass time ago it was like the
producer when he was recording lonely
and the producer like are you good man
it's like lone leave so alone and the
guy's like I'm Mr Lon he like should we
pause you need a hug so we send like a
cease and desist cuz I'm actually here's
I'm a little I fuck that guy he put
lights he put lights up for his country
he put like G like so many lights called
senagal um is where he's from you don't
remember this that he this girl you have
seen this girl on stage that he brought
up on stage and like dry humped her she
was 15 years old oh my God why can't I
get into anything everything has got ad
blockers how do I get out of these ad
blockers I don't even know what to do
well it's right there see this is how he
avoided jail time that no the the jury
didn't want to go through the ad blocker
I was like I was fine he seems Inn I'm
not trying to back the fact of that I'm
just it's just to do a song that's about
like let's go it's Miranda costro being
like probably and I'm like either pay
her for it pay us it's it's my property
cuz we own our podcasts like you
probably own your podcast like there's
so things that we own and I know that he
just went oh these are girls who gives a
I'm just going to steal this property
from them and not credit them not
license is it a good song it's kind of a
Bop that's the part that's the part but
then I also was like I invite moranda
costro this Angel kind of a b b b i you
know okay I'm charging you for that
sorry um also Miranda costro like I just
feel like we she's we become she comes
on my podcast we kind of become friends
and then I just like exp ruin life I got
now every interview she does they're
like say it say it she's like probably
fuck I know I feel bad she was like a
Nickelodeon squeaky clean delight and as
soon as we became friends it's just her
life she's just like an animal now that
is interesting her life is just so what
did aon's people team say it was
basically like a cease and assist of
like you guys need to pay us residual
like you know like it would be like a
co-writer on the song or like you just
option it or you know you license it or
whatever basically the email back was
essentially like get in
line like the number of lawsuits against
Aon at this point they were just like
this is going to take a couple years for
us to like get to it holy we looking
into it like they were just like you
know that was kind of the response wow
and then I was like oh and then you have
to pay a lawyer in order to sue somebody
you know and I was like I don't want it
to get to sue but I think they took it
down like off the internet and stuff but
I just it was more being protective of
Miranda that's yeah I see that I get it
now at first I thought you were just
like man F cam sue them no no no no I I
don't do that kind of all you know yeah
you don't as that person yeah I'm like
reparations black people take it make
money off our podcast well you have so
much going on in your life it's like
you're so busy already it's like the
last thing you want to do is be in a
courtroom being like they use my sound
bite I kind of do would would you guys
not watch a live stream of me and Aon in
court I'd watch a live stream of you
guys doing something else but not in
court
yeah it was just like this Wild Thing
where it's like I I cuz I know his logic
they were like oh it's fine well well
because it came from like a Tik Tok clip
but the where it came from is so much
bigger but if it was like you they'd be
like let's call his lawyer let's just
make sure this is cool and you'd
probably be like it's fine because you
want to be friends with Aon so badly um
but like didn't even email or ask
permission or no that's what it was get
them on the show they did email and ask
permission and I didn't respond to it
and they did it anyway how long before
the email was sent before it came out
was it like the next stay or they're
like hey we want to use this I would
rather have someone steal from me than
check an email so I don't know the
answer to that well okay I cannot I feel
like at this point checking email is
checking the actual mailbox you know
what pisses me off and this is super
Niche is how fast out of office
responses come back like I've been
working all morning to send out like
this like whole thing I'm just sending
notes back to this whole special there's
12 people on it the second you hit enter
it's like I'm in Cabo I don't give a
fuck it is like getting stuffed by the
it's like shooting a basketball and
somebody like out but it's so quick the
second you hit enter it's like hey I'm
not here okay don't tell me just don't
responded it to take 30 minutes yes
exactly it's just like that instant you
it is like getting blocked you're
working on this whole email all day
you've been in the gym you finally go to
shoot first quarter he's open boom the
fuck out of here yeah I'm at a wedding
in
Sacramento oh okay and then they give
you other options I'm out of of town but
you can email this person I don't know
what the that is my favorite are the
people that send the out of office
replies and then they'll reply 10
minutes later yeah yeah you so don't put
it out of office and I know that I'm
like a Workhorse and like everybody
respects their time and all that just
don't even put out of office like
respond when you respond you know
they're so annoying it's like I'd rather
not get a response for day and then I go
like hey falling open it's like oh sorry
man I'm in Cabo oh all right uhhuh like
I know it's the right thing to do it's
the speed at which it comes back uhhuh
yeah no it is aggressive it's like when
you shoot a text and br's like this
number has now been changed you're
like I just feel dumb it is like let me
can I let this land for can I can I
enjoy the victory of having micro do
micro do you're out of offices you know
like like make let me feel good about it
or you know I don't know what do you do
if you're really into a girl marry her
okay no what say we'll get to that and
her email is like sparkle girl 424 for
at like hot mail when did she make
it if she made it in like 2022 like
goodbye psych War been into guys and
then seen their email address and been
like yeah why is that I feel like
growing up I'm like you weren't able to
get like Eric Marks One Two you had to
do one 124 not I made a whole sketch on
that of just like how embarrassing it is
saying it out loud I mean it's like yeah
that's right you got to you got to just
make uhhuh a burner and then a regular
like burner is where you send out your
spam mail like I still have that and it
is cringy as but I made it like eighth
grade I would never give that out uh but
yeah I mean I I think it is fun it just
shows you like how simple somebody can
be like a guys will be like the football
player 44 and you're
like when did you play football football
yeah well that was taken and 44 is my
favorite number go Chiefs and you're
like oh God I couldn't imagine dating
man just a bunch of idiots you know
what's
weird like would you be would you be mad
if every Sunday he was like like this
guy is never excited to go to any event
with you never do anything and then one
Sunday morning he's up at 700 a.m. he's
like yeah well they're playing
International babe so I got to be up and
I got to watch dur in the final four and
this could win us a lot of like I would
if I was a woman I'd be so dry big do
you get up for this other and look I
know I'm in the wrong I don't watch
sports so I don't know but like I but I
guys are just so funny is wild when
you're like my dude setting like his
alarm to watch other men exercise it is
a little wild like you can't tell me
that's not like insane it's a little
bonkers and like he'll yell at me if I
speak that day like at all um when
they're sports playing or just in
general yeah well look bab the game is
tomorrow shut the fuck up I'm a
different person and probably deserve it
24/7 but also it's like I do cuz I have
a lot of guy friends cuz I have a lot of
friends that are comics and I hear some
of the are doing and I'm like so cringe
like both sides are cringe but I hear
yeah so it's like you were talking about
this in your special when I think guys
um have to sit through girls talking
about their exes constantly that or
maybe that was on your podcast yeah yeah
no it was on there and I'm like what are
you doing like you're just making the
guy picture you getting fed by a crazy
and when girls are like and he was a
stalker and he was so C and he was such
an asshole and he was this I'm like this
is making you look terrible yeah his
chapter to and can you stop telling me
how crazy your ex is who's going to
probably knife me in the part like why
would you tell me just I'm like
delusional I just pretend they've never
dated anybody they I don't like I don't
need to hear anything about it also the
Comon it's that time of night where I'm
stuttering the common denominator and
all your crazy exes is you bitch it just
makes you look nuts right because I
think somebody can feel that they that
the person that the ex was crazy but
they don't have to like lead with that
it's it it I don't know what do you talk
about on a first date I don't date
people they text me for like a month and
they just like move in my house first
dates are they either feel like a
podcast or where you're just like yeah
growing up in Southern California so
cool I love comedy what do you do for
you know or it just feels very like I'm
in my and the problem with me is like I
I want a girl who I can like riff with
but that's like asking a lot like like
like energy wise like if I'm going 100
miles an hour I'm like oh look at what
that guy ordered and then I try to make
like a common denominator joke to get
her in on it too and she's like yeah
golden doodles aren't actually gold and
I'm
like so the problem is is like I want a
girl that I can like riff with because
sored bringing my ex but we could riff a
lot it was fun we're not on a date you
can bring up your a what's up but um
yeah I mean that's just like something
so first dates are either super fun or
they're like there's here's the trick
about that though a guy gave it to me
straight recently there have been a
couple guys that just had the kind to
tell me like I have this theory that you
know don't go to your girlfriends for
advice about guys and don't go to your
guy friends like if you want advice
about girls go to your girlfriends you
know what I mean and definitely don't go
to your single girlfriends for advice
about dating or being in a relationship
yes go to your married friends whatever
so um where am I going with this it's
smart I swear um I had one guy say to me
once um I was you know I was just like
younger and a little arogant and would
like give it back to him and
like and he was like why are you doing
this and I was like well I'm the why
would you date me if you weren didn't
want an equal and like I'm the girl you
date if you want to challenge and he
just went why would any guy want to
challenge yeah in their relationship and
I literally was like yeah it's got to be
a team effort like I it didn't even
occur to me and then a guy said to me
recently because I was like I'm confused
do guys want a girl who's funny or a
girl who's not funny because I feel like
sometimes when I'm funny it bothers them
and if I'm not you know I don't know
what to do and he went guys want a girl
who's funny but doesn't want them to
make fun of
him okay you know what I mean yeah like
be funny but not at my expense so I
think girls like I'm funny and we're
being funny but you and you and your
stupid shirt and like yeah I mean the
opening line that I'll never respond to
in my life is I'm funnier than you
no it just it doesn't give me anywhere
to it does give me somewhere to go but
it's a cliff and I don't know like like
how am I supposed to respond to that all
right let me see a tight seven clean let
go that's like a psychopath yeah nice
Michael Cox drop yeah cut that out I'm
just kidding like that's just to me I
don't know that's just but it's a
challenge it's already putting down as
someone who's funnier than you I'm
kidding you are that's not true but but
it's it's just like nothing about that
makes me want to prove myself no like I
don't know it's it's just a funny
opening thing it is interesting that you
talk about getting married I want
to what about it Whitney Cummings will
you sure noo wait so
where what's going on don't even think
about it okay
cool uh I want I I think I want to like
and this sounds dumb but I want to work
my ass off all like through my 30s and
then like at 40 be like right now what I
feel like I'm pretty established I can
settle down I want to see where I'm at
in a relationship if I'm with somebody
great you know are things going well and
like think about a family I are people
your age getting want to get married how
old are you not industry people but like
my friends that I went to college with
and grew up with yeah there are a lot of
them getting married how old are you 30
okay so like a lot of my college friends
are getting married Hometown friends
have like five kids already um they're
just pumping them out yeah Gunther
Luther a lot of fun names uh but yeah
it's like but but like also
like I don't know I look at my friends
getting married and I'm
like I also find though it's interesting
like an our business like will frell
Steve craw like all like the most
successful comedy people jut out like
they have very stable boring I was you
know risking to say relationships and
lives and they're not out I see so many
people who should be further in their
career bigger but they waste so much
time and energy on dating and sleeping
around and putting up numbers and it's
sort of like I feel like it's like it
you're just like grounded you just like
you I don't know it's like it's very
routine it's like you have a wife and
kids you go to work you come back you
hang out with your kids do this with
your wife I mean sure like you I think
you said it was like might be a little
more boring but like yeah like boring in
a good way and by boring I mean people
like us were so manic we confing in like
a stable way in Serenity yeah it's like
chicken or rice for dinner every night
you're like it works it's like your job
should be the most stressful part of
your life like our work should be the
most stressed I see guys going home to
drama and and like they're just like not
putting time into writing or doing stuff
and I think it's like the person that
you date and ultimately settle down with
is a business decision yes you know cuz
it's going to make her break yeah and
they have to be supportive of whatever
travel or whatever you're putting in
hour wise for work but haven't quite yet
found that for me when something ends I
kind of just go like I feel
like this isn't my forever dude do
something just click and you're
like I can fall I I need one little
thing it's weird it's not like a bigger
thing it's like a but is that like the
tip of the iceberg then there's a lot
behind it maybe that's probably a good
way of putting it you know um I kind of
will see one thing or one thing will be
said and I like can never get over it
yeah it's interesting and I'm kind of
like am I a psychopath well it's like I
remember growing up I ate a blueberry
and I saw the inside was green and I was
I was like never again I'm off with
blueberries and sometimes that's what
dating is yeah is is somebody will say
something guys and girls they'll say
something and they
like that's the green and the blueberry
it's just kind of I can never look at
you the same way anymore yeah do you
have any funny examples it doesn't have
like if a guy says
crashing what do you mean like you have
you seen my new show crashing like no
get out of here what like sort of like
I'm gonna go to St Louis I'm just like
crash with my friend yet oh yeah I got
you you mean you're going to stay with
him you're still saying crash like what
like it's like a little thing like that
this is going to make me sound really
insensitive and like a sociopathic
asshole but one time I was like with
this dude and he's wearing these shoes
that are like they're like lace up kind
of
Jack
[Laughter]
sparrowyoutube
and I just I'm not such an asshole that
I just like fell out of love with
someone because they showed some kind of
physical weakness it was just the fact
that he was wearing shoes that were so
he was so not prepared for life for to
defend anyone in any capacity and like
that was kind of it but now I like look
for it because like I was with a girl
the other night and uh I was by the comi
store I was looking for parking and one
lot I go to the one I was go to it was
full I was like I'll just go to another
lot go to a second lot right by the the
pink dot I go and the guy's like oh
we're full and I'm like two lots I'm 0
for two and I'm I'm like with this girl
she's super nice I'm like dude this is
if I was a girl I'd be like one more lot
I'm not blowing this man I go with a
third lot and they're full I literally
had to pay the guy Saddle Ranch extra to
be like can I park here and go to The
Comedy Store but I was like 0 for three
on lots and I was like imagine being a
girl in that seat and you're like this
guy can't even Park a Tesla I am blowing
his roommate so quick I actually think
that it's more the way the guy talks to
the parking lot attendant if you're like
hey chief I'm like Chief's crazy Chief's
crazy out the gate I will really like a
guy and he'll be like what's up boss I'm
like he's a valet you know that he's no
one's boss it's such a power move it's
almost more patronizing to call someone
that is so vastly under you and about to
park your car like what's up boss it
just feels like he's trying to like pull
like some like like some weird move like
I'm going parking myself don't worry
about it what hey brother hey boss like
just sir can I park but that's what it
feels like in these first stages of
dating it feels like a game of uh what's
that mind sweeper where you Soler what's
the one where you step on and there's
not bombs mind sweeper mind
sweeper it feels like each date is like
a game of Mind sweeper like did I say
anything yeah to blow this data you know
I think it's also just like when someone
is trying to impress you you can feel it
yeah yes you know what I mean so it's
like that kind of thing so it's it's
it's less what you're doing it's more
the fact that you're trying to impress
me which is so annoying cuz you should
try to impress someone on a first date
but trying too hard is just repellent
yeah I mean you see it all over town you
just see a guy in like a Lamborghini Ur
just pulling up just the loudest
car that's so
embarrassing you're taking her to the
pink tacos sir yeah and the the the
Lamborghini rentals do back in two hours
you're GNA have to just like the amount
of shows and I'm sure you see this all
the time out here too it's just like
when they turn the lights on the laugh
Factor The Improv and you see the
audience and there's inevitably some
like 60-year-old dude with like a 22y
old and you just want to be like
everybody get everybody stop don't leave
the showroom you guys on stage now
what's going on here what do what do you
guys talk about what what what are your
commonalities what was his opening line
a a RP and me
baby I just realized cuz I just came
from like dating someone that I think
was just too young for me and he was
only like you know like 10 years younger
I guess that sounds like a lot but I
realized the most important thing to me
in a relationship at this point is
having the same song references and
movie references I've always dated like
older where I'm like who's holl notes
like what or like I don't know Johnny
Cash songs I know who he is but like
when you're on a road trip and you seem
so into this and I'm trying to pretend
I'm into this but then if I'm dating
someone younger I have I'm like so Eve
was the first rapper in rough I feel
like I'm lecturing I almost feel like
the key is to just date your same exact
age you got to be on the same page with
the references and there's some things
that can only be explained by saying
like remember in Fast and Furious 3 when
he grabs like sometimes that's the only
way to convey your point you're like
remember the scene in No Country For Old
Man when he goes into the gas that's how
I feel today I agree it's got to be the
same like humor level and in and around
the references I agree cuz cuz then I
feel like they start asking questions
that might be disrespectful the big wait
so was the Titanic real and you're like
oh
my there is a conspiracy theory oh god
let's not get that it's getting late for
Whitney switched out to a boat called
the Olympus Earth is flat Olympus yeah
exactly yeah I do want to write this
movie after I finish what I'm working on
now about um a woman who's 40 who's
dating guys like 25 and they fall movie
Just Vlog it wa what are you talking
about I just like air my ring camera
footage and it's about like he's in love
with he's like so sick of dating these
like young influencers where he has to
like take pictures of them in front of
wing walls on dates you know what I mean
and like wants to date an older woman
but doesn't know any any like 90s song
so he has to like like learn every 90s
song and like watch every 90s movie and
play every 90s video game to like
understand her and then she's got to
like learn Snapchat and all this other
like understand him so ah yeah it's
coming of tail ages that's not what they
say coming of Ages coming of tail ages
I'm just saying words at this point
that's saw horse horses have tails I
don't really know I love your brain like
I love how fast it is I love how chaotic
it is the best way I'm glad I feel it's
really good because you also have that
same brain it's just like it's like a
pingpong match starts out slow like g g
g and then we'll take like little LOLs
where we make no sense and then we'll
like come back and then like we kind of
cancel each other out yeah like somebody
flubs a word m my senses don't make
sense but then it like levels out and
then it's like
I'm such a fan of yours as a person I'm
glad that we're real friends have I done
the most appearances on this podcast
this is number three for me whoa I think
Nikki Glazer might be more people love
me and Nicki Glazer just TI at the top
like rambling about insecurities for
some reason both very funny women huh
would you ever dat a comic yeah I think
so because I feel like if anybody's
going to get the schedule it's going to
be another comic yeah that's true um
yeah it's it's I mean
don't like are you insane yeah I mean
I'm open to you know I'm open to trying
pretty much anything that it's like okay
we dated didn't work you know can I ask
you one last thing please what other
press matters like like I had this
special come out and I'm like I have
about two weeks to like that I'm going
to commit to doing this I did like
Kimmel like whatever that kind of stuff
and then I'm like I'm doing I did Rogan
doing I did Tiger Bell I did Santino
like you'll do all these rounds h3h like
what are the if you're G to go on five
podcasts what are they going to be I
don't even think it's podcast I think
it's half half podcast so what I'm doing
I'm going to New York next week and I'm
doing I'm doing some podcast obviously
but there's a lot of it's like I'm just
shooting Tik Tok content
creators it's like that that's where the
views are because the the goal is to
just raise overall awareness of Whitney
comings what's Whitney up to oh she got
a special out and then they go to follow
you and then they see the the trailer on
your site yeah the podcast
realm it's there's a ceiling you you did
Rogan right you don't need to do other
podcasts I remember I hit up Tim when he
put out his special and he just did
Rogan and h3h3 and I was like yo man if
you want to come on a promo he goes I'm
tapped out I did Rogan I did it that's
like what else you gonna do you know so
it just feels like it's a good point the
podcast Market if you listen to Rogan
there's a good chance you listen to a
bunch of other podcasts and not to say
that it hurts to do all these other
podcasts I think is great because they
have their loyal fans and if anybody's
going to check out a com special it's
going to be podcast fans but I'm trying
to get in front of the people who just
like they have a series like like you
know Daniel Mack on Tik Tok he's guys
like what do you do for a living in the
cars oh yeah stuff like that it's like
how cuz those videos have you realize
when people tell me like you know the
guy that made millions and millions of
dollars by asking people what they do in
their car I just want to put a gun in my
fucking gullet but but but there's that
angle but there's also the angle that
goes was like okay I'm a professional
comedian how can I make his videos funny
in a Whitney sense and that does 10
million views what podcast besides
Rogan's is Gonna Get You 10 million
views you know it's like if if you I I
did a video with Daniel Mac and I don't
remember it did a fuck ton of views I
don't know but I wasn't promoting
anything at the time so now I'm like you
know you're so funny it's like you take
a simple format and you can shit on it
or you can be like how can I just relate
sorry if this is mansplaining I I'm just
no no no I first of all I Am So Pro
mansplaining it is ridiculous how else
are we going to
learn I have a niece who is in college
and she'll call me she like my professor
is mansplaining me I'm like bitch it's
that's called teaching you're dumb he's
smart like is this what happens when
like like female doctors go to medical
school they're like this professor's man
spining me I'm like how else are we
going to learn this you should write
that down they know all the yeah thank
you please mansplain to me but I think I
think it's um it's going to anybody who
you work with and be like hey I why
don't you just research who are the top
Tik tokers in Austin who are the top Tik
tokers in you in New York LA and then
it's like it's like what can I do with
these guys where I can pop in and dude
it takes 10 minutes to film the fact
that I was just like I'm doing all this
New Media enlisted five men that are
literally 50 years old I was like I'm
doing Rogan Bobby Le Santino like what
the but those are great podcasts because
I think the conversion right of people
those are the people who are more likely
to check out a specials podcast fans
right but if uh you know if if a video
with one of these big Tik Tok things
gets 10 million you you would imagine
10,000 people from that would go check
it out it's still a lot of people right
and it's still just a lot of views a lot
of views just looking at you so it's
like when you hit the podcast audience
you're only hitting this Market but I'm
like it's a giant vent diagram there's
no one way to do it I don't know this my
first PR run I don't know what the fuck
I'm doing right I don't know what I'm
doing wrong I don't know I'm doing right
but I also think it's cool for you to do
establishment comedian that sounds weird
like like do like are you garbage do
like cuz I think it's like for you A lot
of people know that your videos are
really funny but I'm excited for people
to know how fucking funny you are for
real as a standup and off the cuff
extemporaneously yeah because I was
stunned really yeah thank you so much
it's also because you're like handsome I
mean there's like a lot of things that
make people go like oh this fucking guy
ladies and gentlemen pterodax will out
now but yeah to answer your question I
don't think they're like I I think
obviously do all the podcast I mean
Rogan that's like the biggest thing yeah
um but yeah I'd also think about just
some of these other random collaps
there's so many people that just do
random I gotta go I gotta DM young gravy
real quick do it he'll fucking put you
in a song then you can sue him you
know I'm like I sue musicians that use
me for Content
hey D here what you you reach out to Aon
sorry about the whole lost thing T what
if you put the first 10 seconds of
mouthy in a song you know it's just
getting that weird like how can I
squeeze promo in without being promo
yeah people hate promo but if you can
like trick people where it's like a
minute of like funny good content and
then at the very end you're like mouthy
out now they're like son of a bitch that
was funny and you got me I'll literally
have people that'll like be like didn't
know this was an ad until the end I'll
go check out this product cuz they feel
like they're like respect you got my
attention and I didn't even know it was
an ad I do think that you should start
talking to um this might be an off
camera conversation but about a sponsor
is about sponsoring like full TV shows
and movies and stuff I think that's
going to be the next the next thing is
like Home Depot presents and they'll
give you five million bucks to make a
movie or whatever it is and one of the
characters just has to work at Home
Depot there's a scene where you go to
Home Depot whatever it is like we're
going to go back sign shal and delivered
yeah of course we're gonna go back to
that yeah I would love to I think that's
a great idea terod dactyl it's on Amazon
Prime right now out now Trevor Wallace
you know I love you you said that with
so much enthusiasm and that is the most
sincere I love you I've ever said really
yeah sorry I'm am I I feel like I'm a
little out of it I feel like I was
little over literally like you're like
you have a child so weird I have a tiny
vampire inside me just eating my brain
as I talk somebody told me the name do I
know it have you said it yet I haven't
said it but I think I've already changed
it what is it who told you editor
Michael uh oh got it got it got it yeah
he is like the only person I told that's
can we can we can we say it it's Trevor
it's it's after his father it is such a
good name Trevor you think yeah I did
say it was Matt R's kid as a joke and
that went pretty viral so let's get this
going you attach his name to
anything Jesus Christ dude um I love you
so much Trevor Wallace pterodax watch it
now it is legitimately fucking excellent
excellent special you know I end these
awkwardly don't ride elephants I love
you
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
la